le 8 février 2021 fera date dans la
gestion des ressources humaines de
l'armée française le passage définitif
au logiciel source soldes pour la
rémunération des 250 mille militaires
après la marine au printemps 2010 9
l'armée de terre en mai 2020 c'est au
tour de l'armée de l'air et de l'espace
et au service de santé des armées
d'intégrer ce système une plateforme
internet plus efficace pour le militaire
il va y trouver les informations sur son
bulletin de solde mais surtout ça qui
est très intéressant tout ce qui a été
utilisé par le calculateur pour calculer
la solde il peut donc très rapidement
dira j'ai un enfant qui n'a pas été
déclaré monty nouveau n'est pas encore
déclaré
donc à pouvoir se retourner vers son
administrant pour lui dire attention il
ya un oubli l'entreprise sopra steria a
été choisi par le ministère des armées
la direction générale de l'armement a
piloté ce projet depuis 2015 ce dossier
fait suite à l'échec du calculateur
louvois responsable du versement de 700
millions d'euros de soldes indue des
rémunérations qui ont été récupérés
ensuite par l'administration
l'objectif de sources solde est double
assurer la fiabilité et simplifier le
calcul nous avons cette année en 2021
commencé de mettre en place cette
nouvelle politique de rémunération des
militaires avec une première indemnité
qui est beaucoup plus simple qui
remplace un grand nombre d'indemnités
pour qu'un militaire qui s'engagent
fortement qui se déploie souvent sur un
théâtre d'opérations à l'extérieur comme
sur le territoire national puisse en
voir rapidement et de façon lisible la
traduction sur sa feuille de sol
comprise dans la loi de programmation
militaire cette réforme de la
rémunération des militaires va se
poursuivre sur les deux prochaines
années